hi
this is lena lee global commercial
product manager for the visel product
line
welcome to the short presentation on
transferring cell counting methods
recommended steps to matching results
there are many reasons that drive
adoption of a new
method it can be obsolescence of
equipment or materials
you might need to increase your
throughput or
you might need to decrease the variation
in your current process
or just general process improvements
in our example uh we recently released a
new instrument called the by cell blue
so when customers are transferring their
current method to the visel blue they
may need to
perform bridge studies or correlation
studies in order to migrate
their existing method to the new
instrument
in this presentation i will provide an
example of
a step-by-step approach on migrating
a vice lxr to the visyl blue
in getting started it's important to
first verify
the performance of the cell counting
methods to be evaluated
there's a protocol outlined by nist
called evaluating the quality of a cell
counting measurement process
in this paper they outline how you can
use
a dilution series to assess instrument
performance
in addition to using cells you also
want to utilize standardized
beads for concentration viability
and also size these are
independent of cells so they they give
you
a better baseline indication of
instrument
performance without the variability
that you may get from live cells
you can also leverage um a reference
cell counting method such
as a culture counter like the
multi-sizer
or z-series or even hemocytometer
but hemocytometer adds another level of
variability
but in in all together it's very
important to verify
the counting performance of your method
before you get started with optimizing
and doing your correlation studies
and here we will begin showing you
examples of how
we were able to match cell counts
between
a new cell counting analyzer called the
visel blue
and its predecessor which is called the
bicel
xr both models are fully automated
cell viability cell counting analyzers
they both utilize the tripan blue dye
exclusion
method
[Music]
the vicel blue is our next generation
cell counter
from the visel xr the viso blue was
designed
with the flexibility to adjust the cell
type settings
to correlate or match with an equivalent
sample
that was also run on the vice lxr
this was very important in our
development of the visel blue
we want to note that complete matching
may not always be possible
in some cases cell samples may have
higher variability
this can be due to either lower
concentration samples
or lower viability or clumpy
cell lines these can add a higher level
of
variation but in general it should be
possible to match
the performance between your instruments
or methods
to get an acceptable level of matching
here we will show you a step-by-step
process
that we used to match the bicel blue and
the visel xr
using typical cell type parameters for a
representative cell sample
in our testing we were able to
achieve concentration results that were
within 10 percent of each other
and viability within 5 percent
the first step in our method for
matching cell type parameters
was to ensure that the counting
performance
for the viso xr and vicel blue was
verified
using their recommended standard beads
and protocols
after we verified that both instrument
passed
their concentration control standards we
then moved on to
run a common concentration control
sample
on both systems so the same sample
was run on both instruments
in this case we use the visel xr
concentration control which is about a 1
million
beat per ml sample
alternatively you could use different
bead concentration standards
as long as their concentration were
determined using a particle counter such
as a
multisizer culture counter and
we want to verify that
both of the instruments using this
common concentration control
did present a result that was within 10
percent of each other
this helps us get some confidence that
both instruments are in good counting
uh accuracy um
and so if they're further apart than 10
of each other we would want to
troubleshoot a little bit deeper
to understand where that difference is
before we proceeded
once we're sure that both instruments
are counting within 10
of each other we then can begin to run
live cells
and here we recommend to use
cell concentrations that are greater
than 2 million
so you have a good representative count
and greater than 50 viability
so there's not too much debris in your
samples
and when you are running these samples
you want to run the same sample
side by side on both instruments so
they're run
as close as the same time to each other
just to decrease that variability
we also suggest to run samples in
replicate
you know perhaps triplicate would be
good
this will help to improve the
statistical confidence
use the appropriate cell type for
measuring the cell sample
and then save the images this way you
can reanalyze the data without having to
rerun the samples
in our testing method we use the cho
cell line we ran the same samples on
three of iso blues and three visol xrs
using their appropriate cell types
our goal was to match the systems within
10
of each other for concentration and 5
for viability
you can definitely determine your own
degree of matching but these are
typically as as tight as you would want
to go if you
uh want to have a tighter
correlation which is definitely possible
but
not always realistic just because of the
tolerance
stack ups between the process overall
of counting sample prep the samples
themselves
you know can add the variability that
you know you
sometimes cannot get any any closer
than 10 for concentration and 5 for
viability
here i just want to give an overview of
what cell types
are here is an example
of parameters in a cell type from the
visel blue
the cell type is a collection of
settings that control the sample
preparation and analysis parameters
the cell type includes the number of
images
to use in analysis the sample prep
settings which are the number of mixes
that you might
have for your sample also the cell count
threshold and the viability threshold
this table shows the cell type settings
that were used
to do our correlation study
these are settings for the vyso blue
which was the mammalian cell type and
the chose cell type
for the bicel xr
with the cell type settings that i just
showed in the previous slide
we were able to demonstrate
that we could optimize the cell types on
the visel blue
to correlate the concentration results
to be within
percent of the bicel xr and
viability within 1.1 percent and
and the average diameter of the cells
were also less than 2 percent difference
from each other
so to just wrap up our recommendations
are that you utilize concentration of
viability standards
as part of your study use cell samples
that are greater than 2 million
cells per ml in concentration with
higher than 70 percent
viability you also want to practice good
sample handling
your samples side by side so they're run
as close in the same time practice good
statistics you know run samples in
replicas
and you want to account for variables in
the process
you know set realistic tolerances and
you should be able to determine this
based on your
counting verification counting
performance
that you would have done before you
started your
correlation studies with the two methods
and then definitely account for
differences in technology
um in our example the visol xr is an
instrument that was
out on the market close to
19 20 years ago versus the vyso blue
which has
a very recent technology so you will
have some differences in the technology
that can add to
the differences within the two two
methods
and for more resources you can always go
to beckman.com
we have a page with all the different
cell counters and analyzers
our multi-sizer as well as our visel
blue vyso xr
and also the viscel metaflex if you were
interested in media analysis
there's also a page on our website that
has cell type
guidelines to help you with cell type
optimization
thank you for your time if you have any
questions please feel free to
contact me at lena lee beckmann.com